These are sounds.
Sounds are our way
of communication.
Our way of understanding.
Have you ever thought
that your voice
sounds much better in the bath?
What is the extent of teachers' rights?
What if you could become something like
an animal? Is that possible?
What separates those who primarily
have an idea
and those who want to bring it to life
is simple.
A society assumes that that is the story
of every black man walking the Earth.
It is assumed that that is my story,
before I even begin to tell it.
Because everything I've just told you
so far is a lie and I just made it all up.
My talk is actually about the art of lying
and convincing people
that what you're saying is true.
We've developed technologies to give
ourselves more and more pleasure.
We're turning into a world like
the "Brave New World" of Aldous Huxley .
This is Ted-ED and this is what we do.